how long does it take you to write a
feature script
so the process of writing a feature
script is hard to quantify in time
because usually if I'm doing something I
really care about what usually happens
is I think about it for about six months
you know I I start to write down a few
ideas I ponder it for about six months
uh then I start to write kind of an
outline of it that might take a few days
or a few hours depending on how much
I've thought through it in advance and
then once I sit down to write it if I'm
dedicated to it
um usually a couple of weeks if I'm
really really focused on that now most
of the time it takes longer because I'm
not I can't dedicate you know eight
hours a day to doing it so most of the
time it'll take
two months or something more like that
do you usually end up talking yourself
out of an idea
uh not too often I mean I guess
I have many many scripts that are in the
in the sort of nugget stage where I have
just kind of written a basic idea and um
I think about it for a long time and I
start to outline it and then I kind of
it's not that I talk myself out of it
but I just never kind of find the time
to move forward with it it becomes less
important to me than maybe another idea
it does
is that because you know that it's got
to be something you're fully committed
to or else maybe you know you might end
up not finishing it or yeah I mean I I
think it's more like as an artist it's
always hard that there are all these
jokes that you know memes and things
about like
finishing a project versus starting a
new project there's a real uh kind of
excitement and a rush with starting a
new project and once you're in the
trenches and like you're working through
and trying to solve problems in a script
that's not the exciting part that
doesn't feel good so it's often easier
to kind of start something new and to
not not finish something but yeah no I
don't think I I ever fully feel like
I've abandoned those ideas I feel like
oh someday I'll get i'll get around to
coming back to this but then you know
maybe I maybe I don't or maybe it hasn't
happened yet still thinking about it
once an idea gets past the Nugget stage
what's your writing process
so again I I think for a while for first
thing I do is I ponder it because I I
think if I sit down if I just have an
idea and then I sit down and try to
write it it just comes out badly that's
not really the best uh scenario for me
so I spent some time pondering it
um usually in the middle of the night I
wake up and I have some you know
thoughts about it I type them into my
phone or um what I used to be uh more
exercising
um in in pre-pandemic days if I was
swimming or something like that a time
when you're kind of shutting your mind
off when you're not really thinking
about anything that's when the ideas
start to start to pop up and those kind
of come together and I start to just
kind of take notes it's like a bunch of
little like uh notes about what what I
want to do with the story or how I want
to structure it and then um
I really sit down and get dedicated to
kind of outlining it and usually the
outline it may not be complete it may be
just like here's you people have
different ideas about what an outline
means some people an outline is a 20
Page you know scene by scene uh
structure of the entire movie for me
it's more like what happens in the
beginning what happens in the end you
know what are some things that kind of
fill in the middle
um and then I typically I'm really
interested in in writing I'm really
interested in symmetry that's usually
how I how I approach writing so I
usually am writing the the end in the
beginning first those are the two pieces
that I think are most important and I
want to make sure that there's something
meaning some meaningful symmetry between
those two so you know whatever I'm
setting up in the beginning and whatever
kind of story I want to tell in the
beginning
ends where it needs to end that it
drives home the the themes or the thesis
of the film
um in that ending and then once I feel
good about the beginning and the ending
then I'll go in and start filling in
that outline sometimes it's
um just you know kind of writing summary
like a synopsis type type of thing in
kind of prose form sometimes it's
actually doing a more seen scene by
scene breakdown like what you know oh we
should have a scene here where this
happens and I'll just write the scene
header and and uh you know kind of write
summary like here's some stuff that
happens in the scene and I'll just work
to kind of fill it in fill in the uh the
story from there sometimes I'm more I'll
do a full full outline where I you know
I have every kind of piece put in
sometimes I start writing
once I have the beginning and ending and
some stuff in the middle sometimes I'll
actually just sit down and start writing
from that point
and why symmetry why is something being
symmetrical very important to you uh I
think symmetry is really really
important in film because I'm a kind of
a thesis driven or a theme driven uh
writer and so the a lot of people I know
are focused on kind of plot or character
or those are the most important elements
but I feel like it's really important to
me if I'm gonna write a film that I have
something to say that I have something
to that's important to me about this
story that's important to me about the
journey that I'm going to take people on
um that's going to connect with people
in a way that's that that it connects
with me and so for me the best the best
way to do that is to look at you know
where is the starting point of the
journey you know where where do I want
people to start from where do I want
people to get on board my my train and
then uh you know where do I need to take
them so that they have the experience
that I want them to have or understand
the themes or have the type of my goal
is to really get people to have an
introspective experience it's not really
about the the you know the characters in
the thing it's more about like what can
I do in this story or with the structure
to make people have some kind of uh
internalization of it or thoughts about
their own lives or their own experiences
um and I think symmetry is really
important for that that kind of
structure how do you know when you have
a great idea
I don't think I ever do know uh I I
don't think it's important to know if
you have a great idea you just kind of
you know I mean
I have a million ideas right I I make a
list of a million ideas every
other day I have a new idea for uh for a
movie
um
I just look at the one that speaks to me
the most I don't know if it's great I
don't know what great great even means
but uh but if I'm gonna write something
it has to be important to me so I have
to look at it and say this is the
concept this is the story that I most
want to tell that I most want to share
that I think will uh convey what I want
to convey that will
in a way expose myself in the way that I
want to expose myself you know to to
other people so that they can maybe
learn something or think about something
um but I don't you know I don't know
whether that makes it great or not I
just know that it's something that's
important to me
do you need others approval before you
give a green light to something to
writing something you know 110 Pages for
writing no not really I think anything
that is interesting to me I'll write it
I I assume most of the time that
anything I'm writing is just gonna
basically sit in a sit in a drawer it's
not going to get made
um you know very few of the things that
I write actually end up going into
production and uh I I would you know
sort of put them out in the world for
other people to read but usually I'm
just I'll finish a draft and then I'll
be like okay I'll sit on this for a
while and think about whether I want to
do something with it but it's not
polished enough to you know send around
or or something
um to do anything else with it other
than have it kind of sit and I'm okay
with that that's that's okay for me
that's part of the process of kind of
finding what it is that is most
important to me I feel like if I don't
write a number of different stories I'm
not going to find the one that really
works in the end for me so that's fine
how do you know when a screenplay is
finished
is it screenplay ever finished I don't
think so
um
it's finished when when it has to be
finished when we have to start turning
it into a production and even then
I don't think it's really finished
because you know if we're if we're
making a movie and I guess I'm talking
about this from the perspective of we're
actually producing the film
um if we're actually producing the film
it's finished we can send it out to
actors you know we can start figuring
out how to actually get the production
moving but we're often doing you know
rewrites after the fact we shoot stuff
and we realize oh something is not
working or we need to adjust something
we need to add something or there's an
opportunity here and so we're always
willing to keep you know keep crafting
and keep reshaping it if I'm not
producing it uh it's still never
finished it's something that you know at
some point I say okay well this is in
pretty good shape let me send it around
and get some notes on it and see how
people respond to it maybe put it in
competition somewhere and uh and then
you know I get feedback usually from
that and either incorporate that or keep
it in a notes file and don't get around
to incorporating it depending on you
know how things are going but yeah I
don't think nothing is really ever
finished
and when you write something let's
suppose you commit to writing a feature
screenplay you never imagine this will
I'll take this to producers it's always
I'm going to be making this myself uh I
definitely do write some some sort of
spec uh screenplays as well
um but it's less frequent for me when
I'm writing a spec screenplay it's a
whole different mindset for me because I
have to think about things differently I
have to think about the story
differently I have to make sure that
it's get what's on the page it's going
to connect with people in a way that I
don't have to worry quite as much if
it's something we're producing because
sometimes we know our stylistic ideas or
our our structural ideas will overcome
or are more important than you know kind
of the words on the page